[Music]
oh let me handbag I should start
speaking more Spanish the trash can't
open thank you no [ __ ] quit look at
it how cute it's so beading but you say
I said hello my people how do you say
that Oh LEM you can pay me anything
mm-hmm how would you say it in Chinese
Laiho all your friend no wait that's
Mandarin translate that literally
verbatim Laiho although a young oh ho
yeah what's up my kind of people it
doesn't have the same like definition or
like how would I can see what it - hey
what's up homies yeah I don't know I
don't know that same how are you feeling
are you sure are you staring at my
bottom lip is that what's going on what
no I just think you notice two of my
speech impediment a little bit I mean
you just I don't know I wanted to ask I
care about you I want to hurt I want to
fill these guys in yeah so I got my I
got my surgery yesterday mm-hmm
and it looks like that I don't know I
really don't want to peel it too far
because they really don't do that
otherwise you do I just want to show you
guys that's not good it's like I'm kind
of proud of it's like my battle scar you
know oh it's like sexy no sure yeah sexy
everything it's like I am it's a surgery
Casey no minor surgery I mean I'm very
um yeah it's very sexy I love this yeah
it feels like there's cotton ball like a
lot of just things here it's swollen
yeah and plus they they increased the
the bone mass there yes I just feels
like a lot of extra weight
all right good tell by the way you're
speaking cuz you're you're like you're
just only moving your top lip oh I'm
like oh my poor baby you're in vain
these guys help a lot yeah I'm afraid to
brush my teeth right now and I'm afraid
to do the mountain why cuz they said
wait 24 hours before you do anything so
my breath is stank right now
and about that it's about that time when
I need to I'm glad that you're glad you
guys smell that thank you oh yeah it's
about that time when I sure probably
started trying to deal with this and
clean it and whatnot but you know we've
got a lot of stuff to do like yeah so we
have all of this stuff just chilling
here and that and then some some of
these boxes over here and we have a Buzz
Lightyear face down you might be
wondering what the heck is this buzz
like you're doing there so that is our
cat Zoe's favorite toy and for for a
really long time we actually had it
locked in the closet because though it
just like so like bite it and then just
throw it and I'm like oh this Buzz
Lightyear's always on the floor this
could be upstairs when you go to sleep
and in the morning to be down here
somewhere yeah it's so cute he likes
playing with it but he doesn't play with
it anymore
I know every time we try to give it to
him he's just chillin Oh cutie he's like
what the heck things in my way oh there
you go oh yeah so today the plan is to
I'm just so lazy to do this but it's to
continue to purge things out of the
house and figure out what to do with
them because we're not taking it to the
new house you know the last time
video the idea was to okay let's throw
out the trash from the garage and then
we'll just start like throwing
everything that we want to get rid of
and we kind of did that but we only
focus on stuff in the garage because a
long time ago we did a video about
cleaning the garage which we technically
did but we didn't actually get rid of
the stuff that we wanted to get rid of
we just kept it big this is us cleaning
out her garage time and time again it's
it's us all right let's do this today
yeah we get in there look opening a
photo album there's like oh the Sun went
down yeah we yeah we did a lot of work
today high-five yes I know and then we
end up just like still living with all
of our junk I'm like uh so finally my
aunt came over the weekend and she just
took everything because like I said
before in that other video sheet that's
like what she does she does that for a
living if she sells things like at the
flea markets slash swap meet so we'll
however you would call it technically
kind of like hooked her up because she's
the one that's gonna be keeping that the
money she makes for me tomorrow stuff
she's on the hustle but she actually did
we gave her a lot of like brand-new
things that are like still like what the
tags are in packaging or whatever
because sometimes we'll buy certain
things and I'm the worst the worst
person when it comes to returning things
that I like if I order clothes online
and they didn't fit me I tell myself I'm
gonna return it but then I end up like
sticking it in the closet and completely
forgetting about it and then the return
window passes so I'm stuck with the item
that I wanted to return and that's why
my aunt ended up keeping a lot of things
that were like brand spanking new like
never been used so hopefully she makes a
pretty penny out of all that sucks
like this guy by the dome but it's so
big
I mean we've only ever used it once
no we've used it I've used a couple of
times yeah I made dumplings before well
then keep it X amount of times our
dumplings why are you getting rid of it
I also tried making my own bread steamed
bread oh that was their nose out of this
thing mm-hmm
aren't you cute oh yeah it's a steamer
if you didn't know it was like a double
boiler yeah so there's two tiers water
goes while you're a volunteer you could
do whatever you want here I know the
tier if you really wanted to make dim
sum this is like ideally what you would
want let's just keep it then we'll
figure out where to put in the new house
we have a huge pantry now true I mean
don't get rid of things that you
actually want to use like that's what
Marie Kondo says like whatever sparks
joy and it's not just about happiness
it's about like does this spark the need
within you to want to use this item and
if it does that's when you keep it
there's not that one back this one does
not spark joy the wok is too heavy is
not coated with Teflon so it's like wait
did it was the one that gave you no aunt
gave me yes this one is this dirty one
right here eyes oh he gave you that one
cuz I'm like wait I love it because it
this is more modern it's like Teflon
coated so it's like nonstick for this to
be nonstick you get to use a lot of oil
and you also have to like keep it
seasoned and stuff well a good cast iron
yeah I'm kind of like I saw a lot of
work in maintenance I don't want to deal
with it just put it back in the closet
this is where we were keeping it before
that's too big in this closet
we have extra hangers our extra chairs
kitty litter and vacuum in this closet
okay
camera them we don't have to instead of
turning it off turn it around and I'm
like so yeah the plan for today alright
so it's been it's been about 30 minutes
since the last clip boys recorded sooo
how's the house stuff coming alone I'm
doing our laundry you know what I can't
frickin wait so we move because this
stupid door issue will not be an issue
anymore because it's pretty awesome in
the new house the washer goes on this
side and the dryer goes on this side and
I know what you guys are thinking why
don't you just manually change the way
that these doors open it's possible but
you can only do it with the dryer for
the hour set if you look here in the
washer machine you cannot switch the
doors to the other side so this is why
we've dealt with this really silly
problem and then I know what you put in
but if it doe good it'll be other side
right right okay well if you look at our
hookups this is where the washer gets
hooked up and this is where the dryer
gets hooked up so we cannot flip sides
but if it's have why don't you just flip
the entire machine upside yeah always
there's always something that you just
haven't covered that someone's gonna
point out okay I cannot wait until we
move home
because that was just really this door
hitting each other thing is not fun
click that's like the most exciting part
about moving in your house we can
finally put my dryer and then washer on
the right side well yeah we've
calculated how long you've been living
in this house March 2016 I mean you're
doing nothing you could be loading up
the bus I just ordered food lunch and
took a while to figure out what to eat
cuz you know my mouth situations and
gotta give me a break you know just I
had to look through post mates a little
longer than usual yes I understand only
to end up eating picking up something
that we always order anyways are you
doing Asian cutting yeah so every time I
watch this I don't put in the dryer I
try stretching it as much as I can and
then I came dry oh nice it helps a bit
still shrinks up but yeah very elegant
long arms thank you for being nice I
love you brand spanking you right here
on this and then we also have the what's
this called not demo
difficult to prototype that's what it's
called we have the prototype - all right
it is many hours later the laundry is
done well almost done the whites is
still getting dried we packed up all the
stuff from the kitchen and I started
kind of packing up stuff in the living
room but oh there you go the dryers done
so Isaac home yeah Louie how was your
day at school it was good yeah yeah you
are slowly inching towards this box yes
why so I got the Xbox for Christmas yeah
and I've been very protective about it
yeah I wanted to buy a case such a
trouble with it oh and here it is well
how did you come up with the money for
the case you gave me $40 that Disney
went to get a souvenir yeah but I never
did so you love me to use $40 for this
and I take the $15 from my allowance to
get this how much do you get for your
allowance five dollars five dollars a
week so how many weeks of allowance to
do three yeah that's three weeks of no
allowance for you to get this case
[Music]
Wow daddy yes oh yeah I took the Pelican
cases yeah that's super fancy now you
could take your xbox what is it 1 s 1 s
all 1s all digital styrofoam whoo
styrofoam let's get it wow you're really
excited you're just like your mama man
every time I get something in the mail I
have to try it out immediately nice and
then here is where we put the HDMI put
all the other yay you finally got this
cuz you've been wanting this for a
minute
yeah for a while ever since I got it
wrong what I'm not using it I could put
it in here just in case yeah in case in
case oh yes insides it goes to his dad's
on the weekends and stuff she's not
wanting to take the Xbox to his dad so
he doesn't want to take it just like in
a bag and stuff cuz he wants to protect
it so he's been wanting this case for a
while now
oh yeah where'd you get those headphones
from from me and where did I get them
from hyperextend we go sick these are
thang timer and your blue cheese teeth
and they're really good quality guys
extreme using them up and then I like
how they're white and they match the
Xbox ahh
looks like we got our Xbox in there
[Music]